[Musique]
depuis l'enfance surdoué à une destinée
devenir champion du monde de Formule 1
après une ascension fulgurante la route
c'est parfois révélée
talentueux défaillances techniques ou
encore pression de piloter pour faire un
rythme une saison 2022 toutefois pleine
de promesses mais surtout cap sur 2023
il part à l'assaut des podium pour
toucher son Graal Charles Clerc et
d'abord en aparté
bonsoir Charles Leclerc et bonsoir
Nathalie bienvenue en aparté merci
beaucoup ravi de vous accueillir avec
une énergie quand vous avez ouvert cette
porte et quand vous avez poussé cette
porte on voit qu'il y a évidemment
quelque chose de puissant chez vous
faites de pas en arrière quand même bah
oui mais moi je découvre je découvre
c'est magnifique un piano sur un circuit
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
chercher l'erreur
j'adore le piano j'adore le piano c'est
vraiment une de mes passions et ça me
permet de complètement déconnecter du
des circuits justement j'aimerais
beaucoup en amener un sur les sur les
pistes mais malheureusement j'ai pas la
place dans la valise donc c'est pour ça
qu'on vous l'a proposé là parce que vous
êtes vous êtes un peu dans votre entre
pendant une petite heure on est ensemble
et on va pouvoir vous découvrir bien sûr
et peut-être qui sait vous laisserez
courir vos doigts sur le piano tout à
l'heure quand on se connaîtra un petit
peu mieux bon je suis super à l'aise
surtout avec des caméras autour je pense
qu'il y aura pas mal de fausses notes
mais bon je peux quand même essayer bon
on verra ça plus tard d'accord avec
plaisir en même temps vous êtes
complètement à l'aise parce que vous
êtes un peu aussi à Monaco ce soir et je
viens de voir ça et je viens de voir ça
le port bien sûr la Principauté le
rocher et oui c'est magnifique très
belle vue j'aimerais beaucoup que mon
j'aimerais beaucoup que mon appartement
et cette même vue mais
j'y suis né toujours bien sûr bien sûr
vous avez vos repères là-bas c'est là
aussi que les circuits et le bruit des
moteurs a commencé à raisonner à vos
oreilles et oui j'ai regardé ma première
course ben justement on voit je pense
l'appartement où j'ai regardé la
première fois
un grand prix de Formule 1 c'était à la
sortie du premier virage qu'on voit là
juste en bas c'est la route qu'on voit à
sainte-evot sur la gauche il y avait un
ami à moi qui avait un appartement et
donc du coup je regardais le Grand Prix
euh de du coup du 3e ou 4e étage oui de
Monaco en rêvant un joueur de d'être
pilote de Formule 1 là-bas donc
petit vous découvrez le Grand Prix de
Monaco les sons le tracé vous êtes minot
votre papa d'ailleurs vous choisit un
surnom vous vous souvenez de ce surnom
pinsar roulette Kinsa roulette parce que
j'étais très très petit dans le carton
on voyait que le casque qui était énorme
donc un pin's qu'on met sur les sur les
chemises sur les t-shirts à roulettes
c'était le surnom qui m'avait donné
alors on va bien sûr observer vos
premiers pas et vos premiers maîtres
évidemment au volant dans quelques
instants vos premiers tours de chauffe
je vous propose de vous installer dans
le canapé si cela vous tente le canapé
alors le canapé jaune par exemple ça
vous dit ça me dit il a l'air
confortable donc
saison 2022 petit flashback et on
commence par quelques images savoureuses
Leclerc size et Hamilton le podium de
Mercedes aujourd'hui inimaginables avant
le départ mais c'est la Formule 1 et le
scénario ne s'écrit pas avant de se
vivre les amis Leclerc dans la dernière
descente elle aura été fiable rapide
solide ne rebondissant plus trop c'est
le rebond de Ferrari en ce début d'année
2022 la victoire de Charles Leclerc la
victoire ne Ferrari le doublé de Ferrari
le maxi oui savoureuse délicieux
évidemment cette victoire à Bahreïn lors
de la première course de la saison
dans la foulée deuxième victoire en
Australie lors de la troisième course
à ce moment là Charles
le titre de champion du monde il est
apporté de tour
alors à ce moment là c'est c'est un très
très bon début de saison
c'est sûrement le plus beau moment de la
saison d'ailleurs parce que on revenait
de saisons qui étaient très très
compliqué pour le team 2021 et 2020 on
n'avait pas la voiture pour pour jouer
la gagne donc c'était un petit peu plus
difficile mentalement mais bon on avait
beaucoup d'espérance dans cette nouvelle
année et d'arriver à cette première
course et de gagner les enfin faire
premier deuxième et gagner les deux
premières courses c'était tout
simplement incroyable
après on pense pas au championnat tout
de suite parce que c'est que les deux
premières courses d'une très longue
saison mais en tout cas c'est sûr qu'on
était on était dans le coup le les
espoirs sont là évidemment à ce moment
là ensuite une autre victoire en
Autriche et puis parce que il y a pas de
ciel sans nuage des problèmes de
fiabilité de la voiture des erreurs de
pilotage comme au Grand Prix de France
vous terminez malgré tout à une très
belle deuxième place au championnat du
monde votre meilleur classement comment
comment ressortez-vous de cette saison
m'agrandit grandit
et pas seulement moi je pense tout le
team parce que c'est vrai que après ces
deux dernières années encore une fois ça
a été ça a pas été facile de de faire un
aussi grand bon en avant après 2020 2021
se battre enfin pour pour des victoires
ce qui n'était pas le cas dans les deux
dernières années c'était un gros banc en
avant après il y a eu trop trop
d'erreurs stratégique de pilotage des
problèmes de fiabilité aussi qui ont
fait que malheureusement le championnat
c'était pas possible cette année mais
bon je on en ressort plus fort et je
suis sûr que en tout cas on donnera tout
pour que l'année 2023 soit la bonne vous
êtes très dur je crois avec vous-même
très exigeants déterminé c'est ce que
dit notamment de vous votre agent
Nicolas Todd comment ça vous nourrit je
suis très critique avec moi-même sur
chaque
erreur petite erreur que je fais je suis
très honnête
et c'est pas un tabou pour moi de parler
de mes erreurs je considère qu'on
grandit après après chaque erreur et
c'est comme ça que j'essaye de d'aborder
chaque erreur donc donc voilà c'est
comme ça que j'aborde les choses mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose de positif
alors 2023 ça y est on est un temps
plein dedans nouvelle voiture nouveau
patron d'écurie place et Frédéric
Vasseur il officie auparavant chez Alfa
Romeo vous vous connaissez d'ailleurs
depuis longtemps cette nouvelle saison
elle prometteuse évidemment bien sûr
mais avec Fred déjà on se connaît bien
alors on travaille déjà ensemble dans
les catégories mineurs avant que
j'arrive en Formule 1 ensuite ma
première année en Formule 1 il freine
m'a fait il m'a fait confiance et donc
du coup on a on était dans le dans le
même team et ça c'est super bien passé
et maintenant on se retrouve on se
retrouve chez Ferrari et j'espère que
l'histoire sera sera belle mais en tout
cas j'ai hâte que la saison commence et
je suis sûr que qu'il y aura que que du
positif en tout cas on bosse tous à 200%
pour que ce soit le cas cette année et
la saison maintenant commence
d'ici peu sur les circuits des circuits
d'ailleurs votre top 3 vous avez
forcément des préférences
alors j'en ai trois
le top 3 je Monaco bien sûr le premier
j'adore les circuits en ville pour moi
c'est vraiment un challenge qui est qui
est incroyable donc pilote on a une
adrénaline qui est
vraiment particulière on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur
et ça c'est quelque chose que j'aime
particulièrement donc Monaco en numéro 1
numéro 2 je dirais
je dirais Singapour
parce que de nuit et en plus en ville et
numéro 3 pour pas choisir un circuit en
ville je vais dire Silverstone
ah Charles dites-moi un mot il y a
d'abord un vrai regain on le chant on a
reçu Jean Todd dans cet appartement
entre autres
il y a un vrai regain de popularité de
la Formule 1 on le sent là ces dernières
années il y a des coureurs aussi
estebanocon pierre gassely qui qui ont
on voit l'énergie la jeunesse le talent
bien sûr alors j'ai bien fait Bro
officier aussi sur Canal+ on connaît sa
verve son engouement et sa manière aussi
nous raconter la Formule 1 tout comme
Jacques Villeneuve vous le sentez vous
cet engouement complètement complètement
depuis je suis arrivé en F1 il y a
vraiment eu une différence je pense que
moi il y a une belle génération pilote
déjà
que ce soit pierre Esteban Verstappen
Norris enfin je là j'en loupe parce que
il y aurait toute la grille à faire mais
bon on est je pense qu'on est on est
vraiment une génération de pilotes qui
est qui est très bonne
mais il y a aussi Netflix qui a fait
quand même une grande différence je
pense parce que ça drive exactement je
pense que ça ça a vraiment
aidé au public qui ne connaissait
absolument rien de la Formule 1 à
s'initier à un sport qui reste quand
même un sport qui est complexe et je
pense que ça ça a beaucoup aidé oui
parce qu'il vous raconte vous dans
l'humanité aussi des pilotes et non pas
uniquement sur l'aspect technique des
choses c'est là qu'il y avait il y avait
besoin peut-être effectivement de
familiariser un peu le public avec ça
avec vous avec vos failles avec vos
histoires complètement complètement
et donc je pense que maintenant ça ça
aide en tout cas aux personnes qui
regardent F1 à mettre des visages sur
les sur les casques qui voyaient avant
et une personnalité sur les sur les
casques et les noms qui qu'ils entendent
en Formule 1 alors votre personnalité
justement votre trajectoire où on va
s'en parler vous voulez bien davantage
je vous invite sur le fauteuil gris près
de Monaco vous avez vu le comptoir rien
de spécial j'ai pas repéré un goût en
particulier mais si on devait imaginer
peut-être
le goût de votre enfance dans l'assiette
quelle est-il spontanément comme ça
Charles Leclerc good mon enfance
je dirais pas à l'huile d'olive parce
que c'est ce que je mangeais du matin
midi et soir c'est mon plat préféré donc
je suis pas très compliqué mais ça ce
serait ce serait le goût de mon enfance
alors d'accord alors installez-vous je
vous en prie
télécommande à droite
ce que je dois appuyer sur un bouton ou
le bouton principal le bouton principal
le gros
c'est pas le bon ah oui c'est bon
rêve c'était conduire une petite voiture
et quand j'ai vu ça première fois que je
suis monté dans le quartier mais ça m'a
plu est-ce qu'il y aurait un conseil que
tu pourrais donner aux gens qui nous
écoutent qui nous regardent et qui
conduisent pas forcément toujours très
bien mais sur la route on respecte le
code et sur la piste et ben on
très pragmatique très pragmatique et
pourtant si jeune le karting école des
futurs pilotes de F1 effectivement 4 ans
tout juste 4 ans quand vous démarrez
faut savoir que le meilleur ami de votre
papa Philippe Bianchi a une piste de
Karting vous adhérez immédiatement vous
êtes séduit à tel point que je crois
savoir que vous loupez l'école pour
aller courir alors pas dans les premiers
temps parce que ma mère était absolument
pas d'accord mon père mon père aussi
d'ailleurs
un petit peu plus tard malheureusement
on était obligé parce que quand on
commence à faire des courses en
internationale les week-ends
de course
mais bon il y avait toujours ma
grand-mère à la maison qui m'aidait à
rattraper un petit peu le travail manqué
quel est le discours à la maison quant à
votre passion qui démarre qui débute
alors on parlait beaucoup de ma passion
je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup de joie
pour mes pour mes parents parce qu'ils
voyaient que je faisais ce que j'aimais
après il y avait aussi un petit peu de
stress en même temps parce que voilà
manque ne pas aller à l'école même même
ne serait-ce que deux trois jours par
semaine sur les week-ends ça reste quand
même beaucoup
donc avoir peur de avoir fait le bon
choix ou pas et après le stress mais ça
surtout de la part de ma maman sur quand
on part sur sur les courses parce que ça
reste un sport dangereux mais bon elle
elle voyait que c'était ce qui me
rendait heureux donc et elle voit
toujours que c'est ce qui me rend
heureux donc ça va alors vous êtes
proche de la famille Bianchi de fête
on va parler de Jules bien sûr lui
rendre hommage si vous voulez bien votre
ami votre menteur décédé tragiquement
suite à un accident Grand Prix du Japon
c'était en octobre 2014 il décédant en
juillet 2015 votre rêve c'était de
courir ensemble en Formule 1
c'est grâce à lui que vous en êtes vous
en êtes là aujourd'hui bien sûr bien sûr
j'ai commencé quand j'avais quand
j'avais 4 ans et la première journée il
était il était à la piste Jules bien sûr
avec son père Philippe j'ai fait les
premiers tours derrière Philippe avec
une corde attachée entre les entre les
deux cartes pour être sûr que je puisse
bien tourner le volant à droite et à
gauche et que j'ai les bons réflexes et
ensuite on a enlevé cette corde et Jules
m'a rejoint sur la piste plus tard cet
après-midi et donc voilà dès la première
journée j'ai roulé avec Jules et ensuite
Jules m'a suivi pendant de nombreuses
années
alors là comme sur cette photo de près
parce que c'était mon mécano à la
première Coupe de France que j'ai fait à
je crois que c'était mais il y avait
d'ailleurs Pierre Gasly et Esteban au
cône aussi donc on était on était tous
les trois et ça ça reste de très très
bons souvenirs et après ça bien sûr
Julie et moi on est resté extrêmement
proche nos deux familles sont toujours
restés extrêmement proches et voilà
jusqu'à jusqu'à malheureusement
l'accident vous avez 17 ans au moment du
drame vous vous souvenez des
questionnements que ça génère en vous
parce que vous démarrez à ce moment là
je me suis jamais posé la question
d'arrêter ma carrière
même au moment où j'ai appris
malheureusement que c'est c'était un
gros accident mon père m'a d'abord caché
parce que j'étais j'étais sur un
week-end de course à Jerez donc mon père
m'avait caché un petit peu ça après la
course bien sûr il m'avait expliqué la
situation
mais je me ça m'a jamais
ça m'a jamais mis de doute sur des
tournées de votre ambition non jamais
jamais après bien sûr c'était c'était un
choc parce que parce que personne ne
s'attend à ce genre de d'événements
même même avant un gros accident les
secondes qui précèdent quand on sait
qu'il y a ou un problème sur la voiture
ou quoi que ce soit j'ai jamais eu la
peur on n'a pas le temps d'avoir peur je
pense et je pense que le jour où j'aurai
peur je j'arrêterai j'arrêterai ce sport
mais après il y a d'autres choses qui me
font peur
les serpents j'aime pas les serpents
j'aime pas du tout les serpents mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec la conduite mais
effectivement
normalement l'espoir d'adrénaline j'ai
pas forcément peur ça ça me plaît
alors vous allez gravir les échelons
très vite Charles du sport automobile
bien sûr alors champion de cartes puis
GP3 Series puis Formule 2
on sent chez vous tout de suite qui a
qui a du talent je vous propose qu'on
regarde une autre image allons c'est
parti
[Musique]
mais cette année l'attente est un peu
plus forte les demandes un peu plus
exaltées
[Musique]
la poignée de main de morue à bene le
patron de l'écurie la proposition de
Sébastian Vettel qui lui aurait bien
fait une place à son côté au moment de
la parade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Charles Leclerc en rouge une aspiration
qui dépasse les ambitions d'un pilote
ça brouille à ce moment-là alors vous
avez fait vos débuts en fait en F1 en
2018 avec l'écurie Alfa Romeo sober et
en 2019 vous intégrez effectivement les
curry Ferrari et vous avez seulement 21
ans alors il y a évidemment un rêve de
gosse qui se réalise à ce moment-là de
rejoindre le cheval cabra et puis à la
pression aussi qui va avec
alors la pression je l'ai jamais
vraiment ressenti bizarrement
mais par contre c'est sûr que c'était un
rêve pour moi qui se réalisait parce que
depuis tout petit j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être chez Ferrari un jour
d'abord en Formule 1 et ça paraissait
impossible à
réaliser et en plus de ça chez Ferrari
c'était tout simplement incroyable donc
au moment de ces images là j'étais pas
du tout au courant
que j'allais être pris l'année prochaine
enfin l'année d'après donc c'était
c'était une grande surprise quand je
l'ai appris mais mais bon c'était tout
simplement incroyable oui c'est sûr que
je pense que pour chaque pilote même en
Formule 1 en général tous les pilotes
rêvent d'être un jour pilote pour la
pour la scout derrière donc voilà j'ai
beaucoup de chance
bien sûr j'imagine qu'à ce moment là
vous avez une pensée pour votre papa et
pas seulement une d'ailleurs il a
disparu en 2017 vous avez tout juste 20
ans c'est lui c'est lui qui qui vous a
tout appris
cette disparition se manque ça a
évidemment changé beaucoup de choses
chez vous j'imagine qu'est-ce qui vous
aurait dit à ce moment-là votre papa oh
je pense qu'il a qu'il aurait été très
très fier
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose où je me suis
toujours je m'en suis toujours beaucoup
voulu parce que bon je vais pas aller
dans les détails mais dans les dernières
semaines c'était un petit peu compliqué
et j'avais pas encore de contrat en
Formule 1 et je lui avais dit je lui
avais menti à ce moment-là et je lui
avais dit j'avais signé un contrat en
Formule 1 pour qu'il soit heureux et
pour qu'il ait un sourire et je mentais
toujours voulu parce que ma mère m'avait
engueulé ce jour-là il m'a dit tu
devrais pas mentir à papa comme ça
mais bon finalement je vais pas mentir
parce que maintenant je suis chez
Ferrari donc seulement un an après
mais donc voilà ça ça
c'était très important pour moi de de
réussir à intégrer la scout derrière
bien sûr pour moi et aussi pour cette
promesse que j'avais fait
mais mon père m'a toujours énormément
soutenu j'ai commencé avec lui au tout
début et c'était voilà vraiment la
personne qui qui m'a accompagné dans
absolument à toutes les courses qui
était là toujours dans les dans les
moments plus difficiles et dans les bons
donc oui je pense qu'il serait très
heureux
vos frères aussi deux votre aînée
Lorenzo qui gère la carrière du cadet
Arthur c'est bon j'ai tout bon ouais
ouais c'est une affaire une affaire de
famille
et c'est d'autant plus une affaire que
de famille que Arthur il est
actuellement en Formule 2 fraîchement
arrivé antichambre de la Formule 1 quand
même qu'elle regarde vous portez sur ses
débuts
je suis tellement heureux pour lui parce
que c'est vrai que pas tout le monde a
la
c'est l'histoire complète de Arthur mais
bon ça ça a été un petit peu compliqué
il a d'abord commencé le karting après
malheureusement on a dû faire un choix
parce que c'est un sport qui coûte
beaucoup d'argent et ma famille avait
décidé de miser sur moi donc Arthur
avait dû arrêter et là depuis je suis
arrivé en Formule 1 mon oncle moi et mon
et mon grand frère on essaye d'aider
Arthur donc il a repris sa carrière et
ça s'est passé ça se passe super bien
parce que voilà il a fait deux années en
Formule 3 là maintenant il passe en
Formule 2 ce qui est la dernière étape
avant la Formule 1
donc voilà je souhaite tout le meilleur
et j'espère vraiment que ça va bien se
passer alors sur ce projet un tout petit
peu dans le futur comme ça dans
l'hypothèse où vous retrouvez sur la
même grille de départ on fait quoi de la
fraternité dans ces cas-là
pour moi ce sera impossible de l'oublier
donc j'espère je nous souhaite que on se
retrouve un jour sur la même grille de
départ c'est pas impossible on est
d'accord c'est pas impossible j'espère
je pense que j'accepterai jamais d'être
son coéquipier parce que entre
coéquipiers c'est plus compliqué mais
sur la même grille de départ
j'aimerais beaucoup en termes de
fraternité d'égo de concurrence
qu'est-ce que ça peut donner selon vous
très honnêtement j'ai du mal à
m'imaginer parce que
alors par exemple avec Pierre on est
Pierre Gasly on est on est très très
amis depuis toujours mais on sait que
dès qu'on ferme la visière il y a plus
il y a plus d'amitié
avec Arthur c'est c'est enfin c'est mon
frère donc je sais pas je sais pas
comment comment je réagirais bon
rendez-vous dans quelques années en tout
cas une autre image allez c'est parti
c'est vous qui êtes aux commandes
il lui reste une victime accélération la
légende de bonsa la légende d'un jeune
garçon qui s'impose
[Applaudissements]
Leclerc en Italie victoire de Ferrari
voilà devant que ça n'était plus arrivé
l'explosion de joie
l'explosion de joie le frisson
évidemment 8 septembre 2019 deuxième
succès en Formule 1 à Monza le circuit
le fameux circuit en Italie sur les
terres de Ferrari victoire à domicile
donc qui était pas arrivé depuis 2010
Fernando Alonso c'est il y a pas des
galles une telle victoire
je pense qu'en termes de podium il n'y a
pas mieux
enfin je suis sûr qu'en termes de podium
il n'y a pas mieux et
c'est toute une semaine
qui est quand même extrêmement
éprouvante pour pour nous les pilotes
Ferrari et le team Ferrari aussi parce
que ça commence c'est pas comme un
week-end normal où on commence à peu
près le jeudi avec les activités
de presse sponsoring etc mais là on
commence le lundi
c'était deux weekends consécutifs après
ma première victoire à Spa dans mes
circonstances un petit peu un petit peu
compliquées
et donc voilà donc de d'arriver à Monza
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de pressions
autour du team et donc du coup c'est
toujours très compliqué de
performer comme à 200% comme les autres
comme les autres weekends mais bon
partez en Paul le dimanche
premier du coup sur la grille de départ
et on a réussi avec la pression de
Hamilton et Bottas pendant toute la
course on a quand même réussi à gagner
et je pense que cette photo représente
bien la ce que ça représentait pour pour
le team
je me suis laissé dire qu'au Grand Prix
votre maman avait pu vous suivre mais de
très loin
vous n'avez pas de place qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
loupé mais alors malheureusement alors
en Italie c'est c'est un très très beau
grand prix mais c'est toujours très
compliqué d'avoir des passes et
donc ma maman avait fait beaucoup de
Grand Prix cette année-là et pour
celui-là on avait dit il faut que je
fasse profiter donc je crois qu'il y
avait des très bons amis à moi et enfin
il y avait mes meilleurs amis il y avait
mes frères et donc du coup on m'a dit
mais t'inquiète pas moi je vais aller
dans les tribunes donc elle est allée
voir le Grand Prix des tribunes et
c'était sur la grille de départ donc du
coup elle avait une une meilleure vue
que que mes invités pour pour le podium
elle est au de la foule bon ça va
c'était l'avantage quand même alors
Charles Leclerc il est là il vous tend
les bras ce piano
alors il faut que j'y aille c'est pas il
y a pas d'obligation rien de
contraignant rien de contraignant je
crois que plus jeune c'était votre frère
qui qui le monopolisé
et puis le confinement s'est présenté
vous avez laissé courir vos doigts sur
les notes et il s'est passé quelque
chose exactement c'était mon petit frère
qui a commencé d'abord
qui d'ailleurs continue de temps en
temps il est très doué
et moi je l'écoutais surtout je jouais
très peu vraiment très peu
et après pendant le covid puisque là
pour le coup j'avais beaucoup de temps
du coup j'ai acheté un piano et je me
suis mis sur le piano et j'ai adoré donc
j'ai pris les premières leçons que j'ai
arrêté assez rapidement parce que la
lecture du solfège c'était pas trop mon
truc mais mais bon j'aime beaucoup jouer
alors si ça vous tente il est là je suis
plus stressé que pour un tour calife je
vous le dis
je vous fais le morceau que je connais
mieux
[Musique]
bon ben voilà
c'est des applaudissements
je viendrai jusqu'à vous voulez faire en
direct mais bravo merci bravo parce que
effectivement c'est pas un espace que
vous maîtrisez nécessairement cette
appartement avec ce piano
en plein milieu on merci vraiment et
c'était superbe il y a une vraie
dextérité quand même chez vous merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup c'est un très
beau piano c'est grâce au piano c'est
tout est dans le piano